well hello again you rad Raider and
welcome to part 2 of gamespot's destiny
raid guide in the first installment we
covered preparation strategy loadout
tips and the first challenge you face
when taking on the vault of glass did
you hear the air quotes i just made
there that's because getting in the door
was just a warm-up guardian this next
bit will test your team's metal with new
mechanics you haven't seen anywhere in
destiny before and some weird enemy
variants to go with them let the
strategic sizing begin first up let's
get the lay of the land this video
covers the three-stage boss fight that
ends with killing secory owns weirder
more successful older cousin a rowboat
thing he called the Templar the three
stages of the battle all take place in
the same area so let's get set up it
helps to think of it as a horseshoe as
you'll mostly be taking up positions
around the perimeter of the area for the
first bit you'll be defending con fluxes
from steadily spawning vex hordes when
you first leap down into the area
consider your landing point the base of
the u-shape send two guardians out to
the left and two to the right their job
will be to plug up the spawn points on
either side and provide supplementary
fire down into the middle area as needed
the remaining two Guardians hold the
line at the base of the you and shred
any robot that comes near you'll be
facing the familiar lineup of vex dil
holes with the notable exception of
these teenage mutant ninja goblins
called fanatics they aren't that hard to
kill but they leave these puddles of
slime when they go down and you do not
want to touch those kill fanatics ASAP
and if you run low on ammo don't be
tempted to dip a toe in the goo for some
pickups
either use those ammo syntheses you
bought or wait until the goo disappears
to make your mad dash if you do get
doused an ecto cooler completely by
accident I'm sure surprised you now have
the mark of negation it sounds kind of
like a sick emblem you could buy from
the speaker in the tower but no it's
basically one of those exploding callers
from battle royale the templar can now
blow you up at any time speaking of whom
you may have noticed that he's there but
he's like super shielded good noticing
don't shoot him don't get near him I
just don't worry about him until later
worried instead about your mark of
negation and book it immediately to the
glowing white circle of cleanser to that
lies in the center of your you shaped
formation pop in there and ah your bomb
collar gets removed freeing you up to
continue killing all them vex track the
conflux when it changes position use
your void Amma junne rifle on minotaurs
and kill anything that moves until the
phase ends nice work you've reached a
mid battle checkpoint so take a breath
give yourself a pat on the back that was
a trick do not remove your hands from
the controller you've still got two more
stages to go okay in the second bit you
don't have to worry about the fanatics
anymore instead you have to worry about
Oracle's these floating stationary glow
blobs appear regularly and if you don't
kill them immediately they'll put the
mark of negation whammy on everyone and
you'll all have to rush into the center
of the map or cleanse the keys to this
phase are recognizing where the Oracle
spawn covering all those spawn points
and trying not to get sniped by the
goddamn hobo goblins that are basically
always hounding your asses from afar so
retaining your general u-shaped position
should give you solid coverage on the
spawn points there are two on the upper
right platform one down in the valley as
you head back towards the bottom of you
a few scattered around the used base
another in the opposite Valley on route
back to the top left end of the U and
one up near the left side spawn point at
the top of you divide up the spawn
locations amongst your teammates and
whenever you hear that telltale chime
check your assignments getting marked is
dangerous because your whole formation
collapses instantly as everyone rushes
to get cleansed if someone goes down you
need to have a backup covering their
Oracle's until they can be revived again
vocal communication is key Oracle's up
one by me 11 years eve that that front
spot yep I see it we got it don't be
discouraged if you experience a fireteam
why 43 before you get it down but once
you get it down Congrats you've hit
another checkpoint and we're on to the
toughest weirdest thing you've done in
destiny yet the third bit of this fight
is when you actually get to kill the
Templar all while still dealing with
Oracle's and killing a bunch of harpies
however the magical kiddie pool of
cleanse itude is now gone so if you get
marked for negation by the Oracle
there's only one thing that can save you
the relic behold the relic it may look
like one of those arts and crafts
projects you make with popsicle sticks
and yarn but it is actually a magical
smash a tacky thing that lets its
wielder cleanse allies shred harpies and
take down the Templars shield oh and if
you drop it by dying everybody gets
killed if it isn't picked up in like
four seconds so the relic is a really
big deal pick your franchise player to
be the relic bearer ideally one of the
highest level players on your fire team
the relic bearers primary job is to use
the relic to destroy harpies using the
are to shield bash maneuver or doing the
leap smash area damage version of this
attack by jumping first each harpy
killed builds the super meter to enable
the relic bearers new super which is a
shield breaking supernova blast thingy
this means that the relic bearer should
be running around near the enemy spawn
points on the left and right sides of
the old you formation killing the crap
out of harpies meanwhile the five
remaining players need to adjust their
positions so they can continue to
eliminate Oracle's as quickly as they
spawn if you miss an Oracle and get mark
of negation eyes everyone needs to run
to the relic bearer immediately to
receive the cleanse they can do by
charging l1 briefly otherwise everyone
should
be busy killing some harpies but not so
many harpies that there aren't enough
for the relic bearer to reap the harvest
and charge the super once the super is
charged the relic bearer should
announces much to the team and get ready
to take down the Templar shield shields
coming down go we're doing really good
right now guys we're doing really good
just don't get frustrated with the team
everyone else needs to a finish killing
Oracle's if they're up and be position
themselves to fire on the boss when the
shield goes down it's time to deal some
serious damage but there's a twist yes
another one no I don't know why I packed
all the twists into this one raid yes it
is a pain in the ass when the shield
comes down the Templar will hit anyone
in line of sight with something called
detained if this happens you basically
been poked a bald and have to shoot your
way out do not try to walk out of it
because you'll take a lot of damage and
probably die instead empty your primary
weapons clip into the bubble to break it
then switch to your special or heavy
weapon to whammy the boss and a note to
those who brought a rocket launcher
along fire that thing inside detain and
you will die while you're hitting the
Templar as hard as you can the only
other thing you have to worry about is
teleporting towards the end of its no
shield phase a glowing ring will appear
on the map indicating the Templars
teleport location you can get up in that
ring and stop the teleport but if you
don't quite make it in time the Templar
will blast you and if you do make it in
time it spawns a Minotaur that's just a
pain in the ass better to just get clear
of the teleport zone and avoid the
Templars bombarding fire resume killing
Oracle's and harpies and wait for the
next cycle and that's really what this
fight is about nailing the cycle then
doing it again and again and again the
relic bearer needs to be fast with the
harpy killing and you need to be on
point with the damage dealing because if
you don't cycle quickly enough you risk
triggering the Templars enrage timer
basically about 8 minutes in the Templar
gets super pissed and starts spawning
minotaurs and goblins and such if its
health is really low and rage doesn't
mean the end of your run but you'd
better make it quick learn the cycle
repeat the cycle perfect the cycle and
you
two will have this moment Sean that's
Bragg the feeling of exultant success
when you take that Robo bastard down is
a great reward of course there are also
tangible rewards that pop into your
inventory the minute that boss bot goes
down and better yet there are loot
chests in your immediate future next up
on gamespot's tremendo raid guide video
series for great looting success we show
you how to overcome platforming
challenges and weird new enemy variants
to pick up not one but two loot chests
then it's off through the maze that'll
take us to the climactic final encounter
you